good morning Millennials I'm sure if
you're watching the live stream you're
wondering why are these [ __ ] six
minutes late and why is there piano well
there's all very good reason for what's
going on here today
and it starts you know with a little
email I got a mere 24 hours ago less 12
hours 12 hours ago from the desk
sorry from the office of mr. Kanye West
this is not a joke this is not a joke we
brought a keyboard for they brought a
keyboard for this I got one of the most
shocking emails of my life yesterday
last night allow me to read it to you
please share with the class tickets I'm
sure knew from the beginning how did we
end up with a keyboard at 10:30 a.m.
this was this wonderful girl who works
for Kanye says hi Claudia
I got your contact from a mutual friend
of ours blank like who knew I'd reach or
friends of Kanye I'm writing on behalf
of Kanye West's team we love your
singing and we'd love to hear your
version of a song off the new Kanye
album before it comes out to the public
slated for Friday please see sheet music
attached and post a youtube video if
you're up for it so not only did I get
recognized by Kanye West in his team
they said they liked my voice and then I
got his new song show them the sheet
music so it's very very real it's very
legit it says closed on Sunday which is
the name of the song and it's by Kanye
West's transcription and music
preparation by Lenny wait so when I got
this I was quite perplexed because a lot
of you may know that we you know where
musicians growing up we like we're a
family band we were a quartet it was
like mortifying and we took music theory
and like I never in my life understood
like why we had to do music theory until
this moment so apologies to mrs. Lee in
Long Island for being like such a
terrible child because everything you
taught us has led up to this place
finally been pertinent to the situation
yeah so we had asked like okay can I get
an mp3 of the song and they're like no
because it's confidential but they're
like they just wanted to hear our
version of it our take on it so I got
out my keyboard as you do as I do
we were FaceTime rehearsing last night
oh my god it was like so dramatic I was
feeling a lot of pressure like to learn
a brand new song is very difficult and
Kanye no less right but I think we got
it to a place where it's like we made it
our own I think it might be like kind of
similar to what the song is going to
sound like and now you have a sneak peek
right toastie version this is a a
win-win for everyone because like
Kanye's song comes out tomorrow but we
have it here first right which is like a
really big deal has anyone ever covered
a song before it's come out I don't know
if you can even consider it a cover like
maybe Kanye stole my song perhaps
perhaps okay I'm like very nervous we've
been practicing all morning like
literally like we are Cimorelli
okay look for some reality like that
wasn't it
they're so cute I mean actually like
they would like the song it's like weird
for me to sing about Jesus cuz like I am
a Jew but I guess I want you for Jesus
and I'm okay with that we're Jews for
Jesus today yeah we look like I'm on
your [ __ ] turtleneck and your
keyboard like okay I mean I'm taking
this seriously meet you I am the pianist
I am Adrien Brody the pianist yes I I
hear you I agree okay Margo with her
long black sleeve like leotard thing so
we have music we have arranged it in our
to the best of our abilities we have
snitch on you know the background snitch
on snaps Jack's on keyboard obviously me
on vocals because like obviously
Kanye did say he loved my voice yeah so
I don't know if this clip is gonna go
anywhere but like Kanye you're seeing
this
we like live for you and your wife and
your whole thing and like just about its
over for dinner one time will it make
your lives and your family is incredible
and Sunday service looks amazing and
we're just so proud of you guys ya know
we really are we're like big fans and
like if you ever need like a loyal
friend like we'll keep your secrets like
that's us we like we're good peeps okay
steel trap steel trap should we jump
into it I'm like super nervous I got
actually I'm gonna laugh and I really
don't watch it okay okay you think about
Kanye seeing you ass oh yeah totally he
would not think that's this is his baby
totally took me laughing at Saint it's
okay are we ready we're ready close down
Sunday
you're my chick-fil-a close on Sunday
you're my chick-fil-a
hold the selfies put the grammar way get
your family
y'all hold hands and pray when you got
daughters always keep them safe watch
out for vipers
don't let them in doctrine nate closed
on Sunday your ma chick-fil-a you're my
number one with the lemonade raise our
sons trained them in the faith through
temptations make sure they're wide awake
follow Jesus listen and obey no more
living for the culture we nobody's
leaving stand up for my home even if I
take this walk alone I found out you the
king up on the throne ma like these
teens I'm no longer a boon ah pray to
God that he'll strength in my hand
then we'll think twice stepping into my
land ah draw the line that's written in
the sand try me and you will see that I
ain't playing ah back up off my family
move your hands ah got my weapons in the
spirits land ah
Jezebel don't even stand it
Jezebel don't even stand wow that felt
like I still need the ball like I'm Lea
we are Sharpay you are totally Ryan
Kelsey totally right
oh my god that was fun oh my god I just
like want to thank Kanye fer
you know instilling this sort of belief
in us like that we could just put
together this arrangement and like was
that better good I can't tell well that
was the best day ever because it was
atrocious before oh yeah that was heaven
we got through the whole thing without
fighting and laughing the laughing was
just it was so hard not to is great I
think was the best it could have been
given like the materials we received at
the time that we were I'm actually
looking forward to now hearing now that
I know like every musical note of this
[ __ ] song like I'm looking forward to
hearing about an album and like seeing
what like sheet music sounds like in the
real world yeah um thank you that was I
hope everyone enjoyed that snaps for us
I think it was like a great great choice
for the Tollison I just feel like one
day we'll look back on this and be like
wow we had the economy exclusive no not
only that like Kanye noticed us like at
the end of the day it's just really nice
to be noticed it is and that's why the
the gratitude I'm feeling today same so
now the question is do we leave the
piano out for the whole show I think we
do I'm feeling the piano vibes yeah I'm
are going you can go back to your chair
but I just don't know like how I go you
know to shul after this you know like oh
yeah I'm Christian now because you're a
traitor yeah but you know what I think
that's what Kanye would have wanted ya
know he's trying to convert you
maybe it's the past alliteration of
Claudius right it's working okay I'm
just gonna get back into my toast mode
I'm no longer a pianist um I'm gonna
call you out why do you sell the charity
easy and when I get dressed I can't find
the scissors and so I just wear it with
the tags until I find a scissor actually
looks great I like that jacket
oh thanks yes wow what a look I had such
a pit all night like I was singing that
song in my sleep I was like ah brother
man like I was literally singing that
[ __ ] song in my sleep I was listening
to
like in my head all morning getting
ready to eat like I just want like
because once you've heard a song a
million times it's easy for you to sing
yes to put to hear it like for you to
put it together for the first time you
don't know what it sounds like yeah it's
crazy stuff it's crazy stuff but like I
feel so how much I think that's really
good I think it was really good too and
like Kimmy rap now like that was all my
adrenaline so when I first got the sheet
music without like hearing the notes I
was like oh it's obviously a rap and I'm
like clothes on Sunday mmm you're my
chick-fil-a you should have heard like
some of the boys tell us we were sending
back from each other this is my closed
on Sunday hey you're my chick-fil-a lady
were really and then I came up with like
a slow jazz version it was like yeah
Sunday yo ma chick-fil-a that's
beautiful honestly I thought my slow
jazz version was like really something
Kanye would have liked yeah no that's
like what you do on the song when you do
a cover on it like after it's been out
for a year you have to change it up
right well maybe and maybe we'll see you
guys back here in a year with the
keyboard with like a slowdown jazz like
you know cabaret yeah look Morgan a
cabaret
yeah magically beautiful beautiful okay
well thank you for sponsoring this
episode of the morning toast yes just
kidding sponsored by said bird our
favorite brand here at the morning toast
Wow our favorite brand from our favorite
show my favorite brand for our favorite
show only makes sense everyone knows
that we love a seven-part if you're a
smelly [ __ ] ever you're just someone
who like needs a scent I feel like I
have a lot of friends who like have a
signature scent and it like makes me
really jealous cuz I think my signature
scent it's just like [ __ ] vibes but you
keep on base since your I've been going
for like an autumnal like more pumpkin
based scent but all jokes aside said
Berta has everything you need to get
your signature scent did you know that
scent is the most powerful since you
have the smell can bring on a flood of
memories influence your mood and of
course enhance your natural style so
Sanford is a luxury fragrance
subscription service for perfumes and
colognes a more than 600 designer brands
for you to choose from each month choose
the proofing me want to try they'll send
you a 30-day supply if you're not sure
what type of scent you're looking for
sort and find your new fragrance by
brand style occasion season and more
plus they have products from other
categories like skincare wellness and
makeup they carry brands like Coke re
our favorite glam glow glow recipe tart
and many up
Plus with our exclusive offer just for
our listeners you can get 30% off your
first month today so it's only $10 for
your first fragrance that's scent bird
dot-com slash toast or just use our code
toast for 30% off your first month at
Sanford again that sent bird scen TBI
rt.com slash chose for you to try your
first perfume or cologne for just $10
sign on wait you know what write me a
little gently put on something on smell
amazing
everything sign on no how do you write a
jingle it's like what do you want it to
be okay
ready first sign on smell amazing yeah I
can't do what's what people can do when
they can just matching piss shine on
sign sign no spell amazed how that
whatever it played then we sing it to
that okay by the way I just wanna say
like I just came up something I smell
amazing okay you don't have that with
piano like the falsettos and the chamois
and you definitely had a keyboard in
time oh good question
strangely have a keyboard in my
apartment because I got it for Zach for
his birthday a few years ago because
it's one of these keyboards that
connects with an app that teaches you
how to play piano which is something
he's always wanted to learn and of
course I got it for him and this was our
first time taking it out of the box oh
but no now I'm gonna leave it out of
thoughts and put it in my home office
like that's a cool thing yeah maybe I
mean they feel inspired just like write
a song or just to play clothes I'm
Sunday you are my chick-fil-a yeah I
mean you are my chick-fil-a I'm
definitely closed on Sundays oh you're
deaf I'm closed out like on weekends
period yeah and I'm taking a long week
nondenominational so I'm off for the
Sabbath and you know
church Sunday yeah so technically
actually yes
denominational yeah yeah yeah okay well
I feel like it's time to get into the
past I've stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your meringue toast even though
everything will inevitably pale in
comparison to the performance that we
launched this show with so true I just
want to like honestly wrap this show so
I can go home and watch it know a few
percent and clip it and just like make
sure Kanye's people see it yeah you know
I'm definitely send it to them but we do
have a bit of interesting news this
morning and the first story something
that we posted to our Instagram last
night um do we do the home yeah I mean
we don't have to do it on our own I'm
saying but I didn't did you say fast
back stories yeah oh my god I totally
missed that
yeah it's okay you're just in Kaitlyn
yeah it's true yeah great place to be
I'm in Calabasas yeah um first story
that we posted on Instagram last night
that I just found to be particularly
interesting is that Pete Davidson and
Kai Gerber enjoy lunch
amid dating rumors too so this is a
really cute couple you want to see tells
great restaurant choice one that makes a
lot of sense he just broke up with his
girlfriend and I don't know if he saw
that viral tweet that Pete Davidson and
Pete Davidson in a wig I did I broken I
did but um this is also giving me Pete
Davidson in a wig vibe you know it's
obvious that he after Ariana I like now
this is like his type because all the
girls kiyah Gerber on mrs. McDowell
what's her daughter what's the name
Margaret Margaret Lee towel and I'm
Cassie David all very much like the same
and I Margaret quali oh but her nuts
seems not much oh no that's her mom's
last me but I don't know um
these girls really look like Cassie
David and it's making me think like
maybe he's just yearning for Cassie
David because I do think that was the
best thing like that ever happened to
him and she'll never take him back cuz
she has too much self-respect for like
the shame that he put her through but
these girls are all fancy David if you
ask me that's true but good for him like
he when he want so what it's just like
he gets so many dates but like it's so
crazy how you gonna be on SNL and be so
famous and you can also be on SNL in
like nobody knows who you are do you
know what I mean yeah and he's like but
he's barely on us and now he's in one
maybe two skits in the background like
he's never really like the star I think
maybe he's more of a writer but I feel
like everyone who doesn't get airtime
yeah but like you would think that he
they would give him the most air time he
is the most famous person on the cast
and ensemble so it's just so crazy that
he is like so famous can literally get
any girl he want when he's like on a TV
show that a lot of people are on they
don't really get famous and he's barely
on it you know yeah well I think it's
his personal life that's the most
interesting and once you're engaged
Ariana Grande
just in a tear of fame that's beyond
yeah but it's like one of us should get
engaged Ariana Grande done Margo set up
you know how like he had that um we
reported a story about him a few months
ago about him like kind of losing his
[ __ ] at a college was it in Miami he
thinks in Florida um so but oh sorry
what does it say it's like so he's on
SNL like if one of the other SNL cast
members like did a stand-up show and
like it like went awry or something like
no one would care you know that's true
like there's just so much about PJ butts
in this like different I wonder why
yeah he's really like a hot button guy
yeah
and it's obviously like the ariana
grande of it all but even before that I
think he was really like on another
stratosphere you know ya know that is
interesting but the ariana grande of it
all was so crazy like can we just like
reflect on that time I miss those times
like when they would just leave their
house and she had an apartment on like
the on the west side in like Hell's
Kitchen I think a beautiful huge
apartment with no furniture in just a
pig and they would step out every single
day and like full glam and he was and
just go to Whole Foods and get packed
and like eat lollipops and he was like
looking like more and more different
every day like with the fanny packs the
bleach air yeah and they were just like
so fashion all fashion no furniture yeah
no furniture I think they liked their
apartment literally has a pool in it
like on the terrace but it's like one of
those apartments but like literally no
furniture
it was a strange strange chime in and I
didn't she walked out one time getting
packed with the tattoo of his dad's like
FDNY I think on her foot yeah yeah it
was just crazy times I wondered she had
that removed as she covered it up um
with like something else
okay she like if you used it um but back
to Pete and kaya I think this is a cute
couple makes a lot of sense he's 25
she's 18 does she live in New York
she gives me New York five she does
because she's a model but he adds in New
York and I think that's important you
know be like Cindy Crawford like doesn't
live in New York
no I'm Cindy Crawford lives in LA but
caius like a working model you gotta
live in LA and New York if you want to
be a moment you be there bicoastal like
us yeah we are back hoes let me take go
to LA ones yeah
so cool they went to see Dallas which is
the most delicious restaurant in the
city and it just made me want to go to
siddell yeah I know that restaurants so
gonna you know it didn't look that busy
which is shocking because there's always
like a madhouse
like you can never get to say well I
know but I'm the oh no they did go to
lunch
I guess cuz it was a weekday and a lot
of people were yeah that's true I go to
lunch we should go there we are going to
be downtown
can we okay yeah I'm starving and maybe
they'll like someone else we'll be there
there's always celebra big performance I
always get really hungry yeah what are
you guys's opinions on the restaurants
where like you're most likely to spot a
celebrity in the city like which ones I
didn't know in LA but like in New York
it's much harder cuz everyone's like so
low-key I feel like berry hotel not
Gemma the hotel lobby which is sometimes
you can't get in holo bar oh definitely
pull a bar it's nine out of ten you'll
see a celebrity mm-hmm where else is
Adele's yeah oh I saw Kendall and Bella
there once I've actually seen a bunch of
people there but it's a funny thing when
when I'm reading the story and like
People magazine about like celebrity
spotted at a restaurant like I've never
heard of that restaurant you but it's in
New York same yeah like when it's in LA
it's gonna be like local Julie yeah when
it's an LA it's like always like Craig's
catch like it's the same five
restaurants like that everyone knows but
in a New York it's like someone going to
like a pub down the street you know yeah
because that's just like the difference
that's good vibe here in New York we're
so laid back um are you ready for the
next story yes it's like kind of cool
Ben Affleck is looking for love on Riya
oh my god that's a dick I'm sorry
I know but good for Ryan that like
they're going from like a bad thing no
this is just a page six article they
have the exclusive page fix six buys a
que like a single person at page six saw
that Ben Affleck is right yeah well
Riya is like this exclusive dating app
that you have to be accepted onto and
referred and it's for it's supposed to
be like for famous people and I have a
few friends who are on it and I'm always
like yo let me let me swipe on your Riya
I have never once seen someone who
wasn't a complete thirst monster like it
is filled with like people thirsty for
Instagram followers like there's I've
never seen a real celebrity on it to
like the fact that Ben Affleck is on it
like makes no sense because it's not a
place for him to actually meet anyone by
ball ya know but it's also its thirst
answers but it's also like a lot of
bachelor people like people who and I
understand like Nick vile can't go on
hinge like I agree every single person
will know who he is like he needs to be
on rye
whereas other people have Instagram
followers - yeah you know but now with
like I mean I guess it makes sense maybe
like Ben Affleck will start dating a
girl from The Bachelor I need my mommy
crazy
I [ __ ] Ben Affleck though doesn't really
need this app like I feel like if he
wanted to date anyone from any sort of
like stratosphere like he could get a
date with like a reality star a movie
star like an influencer like he get like
this app it's so public and honestly
like now there's an article written
about him I'm sure he's wishing he
didn't [ __ ] sign up yeah honestly
made him do it necessary you know yeah
he's young millennial assisted by
Melanie by interesante
I won't happiness for him he seems like
a sad fella he seems broken yeah
remember when he became Batman and there
was a worldwide outrage like that was so
sad I was actually watching um The Dark
Knight with um Heath Ledger Kazak was
watching it and I don't we never grew up
on superhero movies so than ever
sis the whole world is so confusing so
we've seen that we have seen I've had
all of the Dark Knight's shoot Bale was
playing a case Scott Disick they're
twins okay I was playing Batman and I
was like I thought Ben Affleck plays
Batman because I saw him in Justice
League right man there are so many
Batman's there like everyone just keeps
getting it's like a soap opera
yeah it's a crystal 2.0 yeah yeah I
don't understand superhero movies at all
and you see a lot of the controversy
that's going on because Martin Scorsese
like in an interview cuz he's doing a
lot of press now for the Irishman said
that you know superhero a superhero in
action movies like aren't real cinema
and like people and it's so crazy
because there are people a lot of the
actors who are like in a lot of those
like big Marvel movies have done like a
lot of like a hardcore cinema with
Martin Scorsese so I someone asked
Natalie Portman like what do you think
about like it's like what he said like
took the world by storm like it's so
offensive but like it's not really I
don't think it's offensive it's his
opinion right and he's just like an
elitist like that makes sense I wouldn't
expect it what do you think is gonna say
I think the Marvel movies are the
greatest films that a sane yeah like it
doesn't even it doesn't matter like
that's just someone's opinion he's not
it's not like he's like banning Marvel
movies from being made or like maybe
like he thinks that it's not real cinema
because what he enjoys like some French
film fare yeah whatever
oh you do whatever you want my policies
eject the man who gave us shelter I
shutter island' I've started trusting
you the weak can say whatever he wants
yeah totally unrelated but someone sent
me an interview that Trevor Noah did on
Breakfast Club with Charlemagne and it
was like all about canceled culture and
it was he's stealing our job well no but
I found it to be so interesting because
he was talking like really like in you
know big turn like he was he was saying
what we say like he was in and educated
much more eloquently um but he was kind
of talking about council culture like as
if he's not a part of it you know and
it's like no bro you had tweets like
that's like every like it was just it
was funny cuz like we have made
ourselves to face the canceled culture
because like we you know aggressively
stayed like we were temporarily canceled
and it's like Trevor Noah was like he
was talking about it like I'm it's like
third party it's like no I would want to
watch yeah it was actually it was an
interesting interview he's very smart
and you know I never watched his show so
every time he speaks and he turns out to
be British it's like shocking yeah I'm
like what we also saw him at so house
and that's a big juicy firm ass on
Trevor Noah like shockingly big yeah not
to objectify men but but to objectify a
man yeah it was it was a nice ass it
sound like I'm saying anything like that
so no um are you ready for our next
story
no but it's like a bit of litigious news
Liz Oh sets the record straight on truth
hurts after being accused of plagiarism
this drama is so crazy right and she
finds unfolded she spoke on it on her
Instagram story this week um kind of
clearing up because there had been stuff
circulating a few weeks back about this
old tweet that said like I just took a
DNA test turns out of 100% Russian even
when I'm fleeing countries
I'm sorry Trevor South African and so
she's like then after that then the
people were saying that she worked on a
song where they used this lyric and now
she used this Larrick and in her own
song and she is just coming for these
people but have you have you listened to
the other song it's like honesty or
something like that I remember I played
it yeah in the hotel and you thought it
was just someone coverage it hurts with
a different word it's literally the same
song but I think she wrote that she did
with other people the other people just
wanted credit but she say
that those other people didn't write it
with her she still wrote it right so she
is now she is now releasing a statement
saying like yes you know what that lyric
was inspired by a meme I saw a while ago
and I do and I haven't have started to
share she had to pay that girl who the
mean was created off of her tweet she's
like all right and I gave credit but
like now these people are coming for me
again and like this time it's not
[ __ ] true yeah and now her team is
fighting back against any and all
allegations of plagiarism quote today we
filed a lawsuit on Elizabeth's behalf to
establish in a court of law law that the
raisins are not writers of truth hurts
and have no right to profit from the
song success the raisins did not
collaborate with Liz o or anyone else to
create the song and they did not help
write any of the material that they now
seek to profit from which is why they
expressly renounced any claim to the
work in writing months ago as the
lawsuit makes abundantly clear like the
two Tagle so it's time it just gotta
clear to stop like yeah the two sides of
the story she's number one on the charts
seven weeks in a row now she's breaking
records and like people who are trying
to like take that from her and like
muddy and make this also messy this
shame on you
the two sides of this story are very
like if either one of them a true it's
incredibly [ __ ] up like if these two
men are trying to take away like the
accomplishments of a woman who has
worked so hard and so passionately like
you are an [ __ ] and you're just like
thirsting for her fame but the other way
around it's like if Liz oh really like
stole these lyrics and these two guys
and I got all this Fame and like won't
give credit it's like Guth's sneaky
suspicious you know kooky stuff it's
like almost Halloween you know yeah I
don't know but if it was Liz oh who did
it like I could forgive ya know
literally take a dump in my mouth and I
would be like delicious but then also
it's like these people say say the
second scenario is true and these people
wrote that song and it went nowhere or
not nearly where truth hurts when it's
like she had a bigger microphone like
you know there's something world's is
there to hear that there's something to
be said about like people who so there's
like a couple instances where like you
would associate like someone like you
heard of a song wagon we don't you like
Darius Rucker you know but it's actually
not Atari swagger something's like an
old folk song but it's like you know
what Darius Rucker did it bigger and
better so I think yeah to me it's a song
there's so many songs like that that
like you just never realized even for
3,000 yes half a [ __ ] Michael bublé's
Discogs
we blame ya having this discography is
covers but like you just associated he
made it so big but like all right
whatever
feeling good yeah that's a Nina Simone
song yeah yeah she gets credit yes um
because most people know that that's not
his song but a lot of his songs are so
popular and like you would come to learn
afterwards that they're actually covers
but there's somebody said about the
person making it more famous like it's a
Glee yes yeah and they're doing the
world is serviced by introducing these
great songs to people who might not have
already heard them it's also not what
the case is with truth hurts no this is
a separate conversation and also those
are instances where they are
intentionally covering songs and
everyone is being paid appropriately
licensing fees are covered yeah I mean
we're both everything comes back to glee
it's really apparent how like so much of
my musical knowledge and just like the
songs that I know and love are
influenced by Glee like I said we did
that they we watch the episode of rights
even it is a Dixie Chicks no Stevie
Nicks so I was realizing I they were
playing all these Stevie Nicks songs I'm
like I kind of know these songs like how
we are like I know half of my music just
because I grew up watching Glee
oh and it's not just like [ __ ] like
holy songs that freakin mashup heads
will roll a thriller
I know Headroom oh yeah when I was like
5 years old but I did we just had a
great question form organelle
still wondering why Jezebel's doesn't
even stand a chance ok so when I spoke
to Kanye he basically said like Jezebel
the website is just like religion Target
or e towards women and in this climate
like they don't stand a chance like they
claim to be Pro women to all they do is
write articles about women like why do
you take down some of the patriarchy
girlfriend for sure um also as you know
music we're always talking out it's open
to interpretation to show I took it as
that his family is like so strong in
rock style and it's like Jezebel who was
like this nature so people the mistress
of evil this traitorous woman like she
doesn't even stand a chance on coming in
and like causing ruckus amongst his
family yeah like the song he seems kind
of silly actually when you like first
read it but then you actually get to the
lyrics and it's like first saw the
chick-fil-a but comparison is actually
kind of funny and makes a lot of sense
and great like it'll get people to
listen to it because he's close on
Sunday it's like that's his day of rest
it's God's day he goes to church just
like she collects our clothes on Sunday
so it's like a cute little comparison
nobody she starts talking about his
family and like how you got to raise
your family and like the
Jesus like I'm not a Jesus lover but
like I get it and I think it was a nice
song actually yeah and the second half
is really like so musically and
lyrically beautifully see them doing it
at Sunday service like making it like a
huge gospel moment yeah and like live
for a gospel moment yeah like honestly
Mercedes Jones when she was Eckley and
she took her to church and she did a
gospel song with her take me to church
every time they bring in a choir at
sectionals or Nationals they'll win no
honestly that the new Mercedes Jones to
do a cover of this song because her
gospel like Bud is very much interesting
factoid she's and seeing the Little
Mermaid's live on NBC also a lot of
people think that she's on the mask
singer or she already got unbale does
the masked singer that's a penguin or
something I don't know everybody same
same on the master Karen yes really I
saw this drama
do you see Lohan as a judge and I guess
cause since in an alley Lohan news - did
I totally forgotten I make phonics until
a couple of weeks to die schuhe Chevy
did a couple weeks ago Lindsay Lohan was
like I think you're Cody Simpson but it
couldn't take this thing off and she's
like an if it is I want my phone to show
back I bought you and my sister
furniture for your apartment in Venice
and you owe me that back and you
couldn't say anything or take this thing
off because he wasn't being masked yet
um so funny she's like honestly she's
wild she is she's hilarious and I'm glad
that it was him he's really just came
out of nowhere it was a beautiful voice
I forgot yeah like nobody cares nobody
cares but it's also just so weird like
in in Australia like he's at the level
of like being on the masked singer rich
like no offense
um look I would do you know and a lot of
people actually think that I'm on the
messenger I get to read it all the time
it's like no I wish like call me ever
take off my mask ever me like who the
[ __ ] is this girl but did you see and
it's weird that like in America he's
like in every magazine like on the cover
of every [ __ ] website because he's
dating Miley's headers like in Australia
like he's like two different careers
yeah oh so did you see the video of
Lindsay Lohan that's going viral like
we're getting out of the car and dancing
yeah then when I was a trend like six
hundred years ago yeah like getting out
of a car and like dancing this is one
song great song was it oh is Kiki do you
love me
oh and why are you driving yeah and then
I don't know what song she was doing it
to but she's a trendsetter I wouldn't be
surprised to take another world by
tomorrow I wouldn't be surprised she is
a trendsetter when it comes to dance
means
those are trendsetter when it comes to
you know her style you know I feel
heavily influenced by no I wore this
today because I saw her wearing a pink
pantsuit and that
I said okay Virginia George wearing
Armour pants flip-flops so I thought I
said Jean George wearing Thursday boots
so I bought those Regina George would
love three states this is a very
appropriate ad for today because I got 1
million questions about the
over-the-knee boots that I wore in LA
all week because as a mu C vibe it's
very hard to find boots that go over
your [ __ ] [ __ ] thighs so I need you
guys only everyone was tweeting I mean
my shoes are from Thursday boots and
they're [ __ ] premium as hell and they
do fit over my thigh and you know they
do mold to my leg over time which I
really appreciate today's Thursday it's
officially boot season just in time for
the start of fall we received a few of
the new releases from our friends at
Thursday boots Thursday boots is in New
York City based startup brand that
designs really really comfortable
high-quality boots and sells them at a
very accessible direct-to-consumer price
they make handcrafted boots in the same
North American and European facilities
as brands that charge two to four times
the price but Thursday can use higher
quality materials and still sell them at
a lower price because they don't have to
deal with the retail markups and
wholesalers vogue named them the best
fall boots under $200 if you're looking
for new everyday boots the Chelsea boot
check out their safe than weather safe
Suede's super comfortable and water
literally bounces off of them so rainy
days won't slow you down
it rains one day when we were in LA and
it was not a problem for us I have the
over the knee boot it's called The
Tempest it's the same there may be the
same facilities in Spain as brands that
charge over $800 for basically the same
boot they literally charge $600 less for
higher quality version of the boot
Thursday boots believes in year-round
honest prices so while they don't do
sales or discounts to giving our
listeners two free day shipping on their
first order and they always offer free
returns and exchanges so you have
nothing to lose trying out a few pairs
go to Thursday boots calm / toast and
you can have a pair on your doorstep
before next Thursday that's th urs da y
Bo OTS dot-com / toasts for free two-day
shipping returns and exchanging it
changes sign on and struck down that
true girlfriend yeah I love there's a
new me too I'm obsessed with leather the
needs that I do have before the knee
boots are like why you looking at me
because I'm using your lipstick yeah I
just think so brazenly when you already
have lipstick on and I was like I always
feel like my lipsticks coming off so I
was 17 yeah I I feel like over the knee
boots for the last five summer five
winters have like been the thing and
they still are and like I'm always
behind like I get my boots in like
[ __ ] February like now I got my boots
in [ __ ] October [ __ ] and I'm here
for winter don't [ __ ] come for me I
need to get boots yeah you look really
cute today snatchler thank you soon is a
chiller this is actually it's don't
Sunday you're much chick-fil-a
[Music]
closed on Sunday hey but they will have
2d monetize this YouTube video because I
don't want to get taken down no I don't
think they'll come these hours with the
tribution and I think they're so similar
it's shocking it's shocking okay
this x-rays are really slow I'm sorry by
the way I just write a comment Mario
when we were talking about thunder only
it's Fleetwood Mac oh I think Stevie
Nicks was it in Fleetwood Mac definitely
not okay okay next to a really sweet
tale of love between Kaitlyn Bristowe
and jacent arctic because yesterday was
their one year anniversary of meeting
and she's sharing the story of when they
first met oh and it was really beautiful
and interesting so she posted a picture
of her Jason and Olivia Creedy and said
well as a selfie and she said emotional
alert on this day last year I walked
into a studio in Seattle and a podcast
with Jason and Olivia I almost canceled
because I had been bawling my eyes my
eyes out in an uber going through some
crap and I was crying on FaceTime to my
dad when he came in and I'm assuming
this was a time when she was still with
Sean but like things were bad yeah
especially but I think they had broken
up for a really long time before anyone
ever knew about it so they might have
actually not even been together yeah but
like the public still thought they were
gonna that's like just start dating
right but she was in a really shitty sad
mood she said we had never met but he
hugged me and told me he had just cried
too at a charity event that he came from
he looked at me and said let's have a
soft tuesday together
he almost cancelled as well because he
had an eye infection he brought a nice
bottle of wine and I had asked Olivia to
join me for the podcast because I
thought I would need someone to help
keep the energy up since I was so sad
but if you spent two seconds with Jason
you realized his energy is electric and
you can't help but be in a good mood her
meeting with Tariq
her day around she revealed and they
developed a deep friendship that later
blossom into something more quote my day
had changed I didn't know what was going
to happen I thought of Jason as a friend
and wanted him to be the bachelor he
actually helped me through a hard time I
just wanted him to be happy so she was
like conflicted right um but I just
think that's
because it's just sweet it's just so
crazy like you don't really nobody gets
to rebound with like a true love you
know and but this really wasn't a
rebound and like they are so real like I
feel like they will eventually end up
like God willing you know not gonna
would getting married in a shorter
amount of time than her and Shawn were
like engaged for it cuz they were
engaged for like four years
Stevie Nicks was in Fleetwood Mac I told
you oh my god it's crazy
we're just striking out on these yeah
yeah it's like I guess glue didn't teach
us that much wow I did not know I mean I
wouldn't even know fluid Mac existed if
it wasn't for clay I wouldn't know if
Fleetwood Mac didn't exist it if it
weren't for Paul Scott LeBlanc of that
club that used to be around that was so
fun that only played old music and every
every night they played Thunder and the
whole club was like swaying like I'd
like it everyone was on drugs yeah and I
also wouldn't know the song landslide if
it wasn't for Cle what he's like yeah
that's the only place I've heard it
first well that's such an important
moment that's one like Santana right you
come out to each other but it's
literally like the biggest song of the
world we used to sing that song all the
time growing up Olivier played on the
guitar and [ __ ] we were so weird we were
so weird I played this [ __ ] here is
something we've not changed whoo oh my
god snitch on the recorder I think you
know flute no I know but you also played
the record yeah I did and I think you
should bring it in one day okay
a recorder I could pick up again my
crossbow and I asked to play the flute
because I thought it was a saxophone
snatcher it's gets cuter and cuter I
asked to play guitar and I love my
guitar teacher so much she was like so
cool mrs. wagon I should like special on
hair oh my god but she wasn't or
anything
look we were rehearsing last night over
FaceTime like I was mrs. Wagner and I
understand my piano teachers are just
like so spirited it's like when you hit
like you have to go high it's like the
notes here like you know and then
there's also a breakage you have to play
like bah bah bah bah it actually makes
sense maybe we should teach music the
toast of school of music very
prestigious okay
HP gluten Sascha be gluten instant
Senay chiefly you could have if you
would like step with the flu you coulda
been the next Liz oh I'm just like not
musically talented like she is like
you're coming to save us incredible but
honestly this whole operation could have
been done without you honey no I think
it could in a sentence sounds like he
said could have couldn't I think
couldn't but I met couldn't tab so as I
couldn't oh my god I'm just so all over
the place today what story are we even
on we're on number four Katelyn and
Jayson love their love story can't wait
like I mean I don't wanna be one of
those people that like pressures on to
get engaged you are so annoying but it's
like I'm excited but it's like just do
it ya know they're really cute and I
can't look Olivia creamy was there for
their jet burgeoning love that's so
crazy like the things it's like it's the
little details that really make it so
interesting it really is the little
details okay but you think that one
Livia comedian will definitely be
invited to their wedding absolutely yes
bid and final story a little Morning
Show News Giuliana Rancic is leaving her
full-time role at enews as the show
moves again or City thank you every
couple of years the giuliana rancic
leaving it's like wasn't she gone she's
gonna mean forever shaking it where
doesn't think she came back for like one
show we deal on the carpet like you know
she only does like Oscars now she thinks
she's like right secret so she only does
like the high-tier events and they leave
like no actually opened up a lot of
roles for Tonya rad which I'm happy for
cuz she's now doing a bunch of red
carpet stuff but they have like multiple
people on the carpet yeah you know but
I'm saying now there's but Jason Kennedy
is like the new Ryan Seacrest because he
does everything and Ryan will do Oscars
and I've Giuliana will do Oscars to Mike
probably Grammys but Janis not showing
up to the Billboard Music Awards no and
yeah it's definitely there they're
diversifying like what people they use
where they have a lot of different spots
on the carpet it's like a whole yeah
they have like the Aaron Lim spot yet
they have the entrance to the carpet
then they have like pine carpet spa
skybox
glam counting 360 yeah they have a bunch
now cam so she like retiring but she oh
this is like the third time I've heard
this story like just retire already I
know well she wrote returning to amuse
us this last year was an incredible
homecoming as the show moves to New York
City in January many of you have asked
if I will be returning full-time I
wanted to let you hear firsthand that
i've decide
I won't be able to make this big move at
this time I love you news but what's
best for my family as well as my current
schedule just won't allow for the
commitment a Daily Show takes well I
think she's very well compensated and
she doesn't like need to work especially
I believe she was one of the initial
investors and that pit bun hmm I'm a new
TV commercials now so I think she's just
like right Hannah and they also own all
those restaurants in Chicago like rpm
Italian yeah yeah it says as you may
know I lead several businesses my
clothing line g by giuliana fountain of
truth skincare my role at rpm restaurant
group which is about to open its sixth
location keep me very active in order to
properly serve these and my other
endeavors flexibility I don't think with
the skincare in the clothing are like
what's paying our bills I think it's
more like the restaurants and the
fabfitfun yeah but get it get it sis you
don't gotta work like that like moving
your whole family to New York like when
she probably lives in a house like I
wonder who's gonna do it yeah I think
you can tell who they're investing a lot
of their time and they love Zuri Hall
mm-hmm they love Karissa they love more
again Chris is pregnant again
no way yeah I saw that that's so cute
yeah yeah um I think Melanie Bromley is
gonna be stepping it up they have like
new but then these people have to move
to New York so like it's gonna be really
two people Jason Kennedy I think will do
anything for a really but it's like a
show away and they are so la yeah oh
that's really tough mm-hmm I feel like
lady said I wouldn't move to New York
yeah here on this show I think that he
loves New York
if they made ladies center of the face
of like they would be so [ __ ] smart
consider is daily pop yeah and they
can't they're not gonna move daily pop
why are they moving to New York well
they should move daily well actually
they probably should have moved daily
pop to New York because I Chrissa and
Morgan like I don't see that moving but
then they could record at noon instead
of 6 a.m. yeah torture they need to make
Justin like the new Ryan Seacrest he's
so [ __ ] funny no he needs to be the
new everything um all morning shows
should be in New York though because oh
Aaron live three more years three more
hours of sleep
yeah Arizona totally moved to New York
yet they're like the young people who
aren't like married and settle down with
kids like they can move around like
Justin
but like the Jason Kennedy is Julian
it's like they have kids their families
eight houses dogs like they can't just
pick up and move no honestly maybe now
would be a great time for e to serve
justice for cats Adler
it's just this for us I think you're
gonna say no it's not gonna happen like
she she's so far beyond it but like like
lets me not forget what they determine
for sure and but that bridge was
thoroughly burned yeah yeah yeah they
both on behalf of both of them yeah but
like if they wouldn't extend an olive
branch check I think like people would
really like respected that was like such
a crazy award season when they liked
very much refused to pay cats Adler like
the same is Jason hadn't even the hand
delivered a the same job at the time and
then they did all those award shows like
everyone was making comments like Amy
Adams like all the celebrities so like
fight for equal pay like doing an
interview on EMU who just let me run
through this big scandal for not paying
their female staff the same as their mom
like everyone's like shaking it was
really it was wonderful time to be alive
I was like living for the hypocrisy yeah
good times good times
well I'm excited for this new slate of
content and the talent that gets a
promotion congratulations yeah if it
can't be us it should be someone else
like they have really I really like the
talent that they have there there's you
know when that really bothers me that no
they procure young like millennial
talent and like a diverse group of it
pretty well yeah here for it here for it
so those were five stories Real
Housewives of Dallas yes oh my god I got
like really upset watching the episode
can you look at me because yeah because
there are so many opinions on the show
today we had Cameron on what two weeks
ago and she really looked changed my
mind about her and I really felt like I
had misjudged her um but then I watched
last night's episode and that thing
about her that like really bothered me
came back and I remembered exactly what
it was
remember when they might turn around in
Colorado and she's having the argument
about buying someone's baby like she was
so wrong she takes one piece from a
conversation and harps on it and that's
what carried uber said about her she's a
know what where did carried uber use
that she like pesters what about like
going pecking bird we you know she like
the the surface friend thing less she
can't get over and Stephanie don't even
say that she said I don't want a surface
friendship with you not we have a
surface sign she said it at the end of
the conversation it was like a
conclusive they had already forgiven
each other it wasn't in ingest like it
was like I really want to like I want to
fix it so that we can work
having like a service level friendship
it was so not a crazy thing Cameron it's
just like I need to understand now more
than ever the whole relationship between
Liana and Cameron because I knew that
something was weird when Cameron was out
to dinner with her husband and he was
like she's having so many parties and
Cameron got so defensive of the enter
her husband he didn't say anything so
quick okay
I'm the Cameron LeeAnn front and now I'm
so glad we did have her on the show
because I feel like I would have jumped
to so many conclusions and I think in
this episode like she was so wrong and I
don't like Sam I her but I but I still
love her and I can see why she does some
of the things that she does and what she
said on this show was just like I think
she just genuinely loves Leigh Anne as a
friend and like she's a sort of friend
when like you are her true friend and
she feels like you have her back she's
gonna do the same for you a bridal
shower couple shower was the most
beautiful thing I ever saw when she was
giving her speech in front of the green
lights like that visual by the way that
venue was [ __ ] stunning like even the
rain made it more beautiful like the
greenery on the lights fine and then
that table and the candelabras oh my god
it was [ __ ] stunning it was [ __ ]
sending I only wish all the women had
been invited to that it wouldn't have
been like this negative a figure that
turn into like a negative happy hour
because it was so [ __ ] beautiful
let's talk about the RSVP'ing like I
feel like Stephanie brandy definitely
could have handled it better and like
done a few things right but like do you
think Cameron was making it more of a
big deal like when she was throwing away
their linens like you knew two days ago
they weren't coming why are you bringing
their linens - that's right she was
making it a much bigger deal than it
needed to be as someone there's a bunch
of different like ways that people
handle these sorts of things I am
someone who is a Brandi and Stephanie
like when I realize that I can't come I
will shoot you a text that like I didn't
have Shakespeare right right and you're
gonna get mad at me for like not caring
enough when it's like I care it has
nothing to do with me caring I'm just
like letting you know the facts that I
can't make it right as soon as soon as I
know that I can't and I very much
understand Stephanie not being organized
like a camera definitely has a you know
big planner a wall calendar for all of
her children with post-its color-coded
like I get it I'm not that way so like
happens to me all the time we're like I
literally have double booked two things
and I just I can't go to one and like
you just have to send a text and it
sucks like to beat around the bush you
just got to be very blunt you gotta be
like I'm sorry I can't make up no and
also I feel like at a certain stage in
your life like if your way of doing
those things bothers other people like
that friendship won't last
so at this point like I'm not friends
with people who can't handle when I say
oh my god sorry like I got caught up I
can't make it like my friends like no
I'm a flaky ass [ __ ] and and they love
me just to say Jackie
1000% and it's like that's what all
these women are like they're so
different and they're forced to be
friends when ordinarily they probably
Stephanie and Cameron would never be
friends for work force right again and
Carey would never act like a Cameron
couldn't be friends with someone like me
who's flaky and I couldn't be friends
with someone who makes me feel like a
shitty person when I'm just trying to do
the better that I can be a mom right no
it was so crazy I was really getting so
frustrated like they had just had this
nice conversation it's like Stephanie
consumed know right when it comes to
Cameron's and now she really doesn't
give a [ __ ] and she had a drink she's
like all right whatever like it was so
frustrating that hood thing was so
stupid and honestly like thirst monster
Carrie juber was pissing me off like she
was at the shower like first of all it
makes no [ __ ] sense that she's at
every single one of LeAnn's engagements
she literally I started a rumor about
your husband getting his dick sucked
literally ruined your life you sat on my
couch hysterically crying saying you
would never forgive her and then we were
thirsting out at all four bridal Affairs
just so you could be on TV I am now more
certain than ever that carried you were
was fired um
I agree but I just want to say let's
look at it a different way if if Carrie
Juber can forgive LeAnn and LeAnn can
see that then LeAnn should be able to
forgive DeAndre because Oh totally
because I'm like Leon should like be
like oh we were bad and now we're good
and you can forgive people and Leon like
still bring up the stand your thing when
it's like so irrelevant a run the vid
it's upsetting but I'm actually glad
that like D'Andra is above the fray but
like my to heart is like breaking for
Deandra that conversation with her mom
like in her mom's Palace was so said she
was basically like figure it out like
get a job but it was just like I know
what probably a lot of people think too
enters in titles and she is like the
conversation I can't know about $60,000
a year just I'm so obnoxious
cuz that's like one of her forms of
income but she's also on the show but
like the mom basically like having
Deandra like work for her her whole life
and then at 50 years old being like you
basically have to restart it I'm not
gonna help you at all but not even that
her mom's like slamming her for not
having a career but Deandra has said
like she used to work in DC right and
she had a career and her mom begged her
to come home and work with her so you
and she like
left everything that she had been
working towards on her own to work for
her mom and end up in this shitty
situation right where her mom like
refuses to help her it's that kind of
living for Deandra feeling but I what's
curious to me is like any housewife who
has a skincare who even starts a
skincare company on the show and it's
like you know base in their basement
like putting together things like they
get somewhere and I don't understand how
Deandra hasn't turned her status on the
show into sales of the product she
doesn't she doesn't do a good job of
like mark she should get a bad name of
the company I know she felt like she
should be Bethenny frankly he doesn't
realize like literally her problem is
her solution like she's on the biggest
show in America literally the target
demographic for her skincare line and I
literally don't even know what the brand
is called I know they do commercials on
Christian TV and they can't afford
they're right in their office like
that's literally it
that's why honestly I have no faith in
her as businesswoman yeah like she can't
even see the opportunity Rijn is out
here shelling Sparkle dog
yeah same company yeah tell us where we
can get it show us using show us you
using it on your face I also liked
Andrew does look amazing she's 50 years
old like what already got your house and
have all the ladies put the cream on
that face right like what do you I want
to know what you're using what is he
called it's so frustrating that we don't
know the name of the company three
seasons now she's had three seasons to
like market it on a huge show with the
exact audience that she wants buying her
product yeah and instead like now I'm
like why would I buy this product like
no one wants it right it's failing right
no she's doing such a poor job like and
by the way also the gifts that Travis
gave Stephanie I know she was like
you're such an [ __ ] but I kind of
thought it was sweet like something cute
about it it is something that my husband
would do 1,000% Hermes box is not cool
no but like giving a gift of all the
things that I steal from him like and by
the way I've used sis deodorant I used
his toothbrush like it was just I was
ecstatic
Ives was so fun it was so funny I was
literally like having like a
flash-forward of my life yeah um but it
was hilarious and she took it like a
champ in shoes I was like this is the
worst gift I've ever received yeah by
the way I'm sure she got a Birkin like
two days later on her actual anniversary
I don't think that Travis is like
holding back when it comes to no but it
was just like funny it was so funny and
so cute and I really it's so crazy do
you remember season one when he was so
rude and like made a list for her like
he is so different and she said that
she's a guy to put up with 11 years of
list right but like he's so different
and she's so different like she stands
up for herself she wouldn't put up with
a list now yeah it's just so crazy
like TV like really changes a couple I
know and I just love and I said this
before the house husbands have Dallas me
too I love the relationships of Dallas
and flawed as she might be
I love Cameron in court their
conversation at dinner was so funny
because he was like being so sweet her
but not like overwhelmingly sweet where
it's like Oh buddy was fighting but then
he was also like giving her [ __ ] for
some of her [ __ ] like you're so
high-maintenance and she was like you
made me this way and it was just like
really funny they were being so real
about like their lives are obviously
like a fantasy
yeah but they like bring us in on it and
she was like being really real about
like I wasn't like this before I met
Cory like I didn't have these things
right and I was happy then too
yeah I just really enjoy their relations
I like the relationship between Bryan
and Travis and I do what I do wish to
see more of Bryan and Brandee but it was
so toxic when we did that it's probably
better that we don't but it's too
hurtful but I feel like they're in a
good place now or maybe it's just
because we're not seeing him a lot
no I feel like her attitude would
reflect if they weren't in a good place
I feel like the baby really like but I
feel like they're in a good place now
and they don't want to go back to that
place and you can't even if they are
still good maybe on TV it will come off
bad like a you know that happened to all
the couples not gonna let go off on
every cup of it's let's go out on TV
right now and that will cause issues so
I think it's best the way that it is I
just really like I like them when I see
him I'm like oh right yeah and the
daughter's cheerleading was so new that
daughter needs had her attitude in check
she's such a [ __ ] and by the way she's
amazing actually like she have really
talented like she could be a star she
could be if she's an alumnus like she's
a legacy her mom was a Dallas Cowboy
Cheerleader like she really could be
well did you see next week that Brandi
says the birth mom is pregnant again
mm-hmm I know like that's so crazy they
would have five kids son no four okay
not that crazy but she didn't say she
was gonna necessarily adapt it but like
I think if given the chance she would
but like you probably feel like so
guilty like you're gonna be separating
siblings
yeah no I I think if she's given the
chance she would but it's been more than
nine months since this actually this
that was like first week of May so maybe
any day now maybe they're done waiting
for the reveal maybe when this episode
comes out next week I'll be so crazy if
she had another child who has red hair
what if he doesn't over there and I was
thinking that like who's the father you
know yeah that's so crazy that was like
that
thing I was forget about that brandy
like randomly adopted child last year
like so sweet
um I broke down my notes of the things
that I thought were funny cause I'd
never do but then I always kicked myself
it was a good episode also it was I just
found myself like laughing enjoying and
the funniest thing was Cameron and her
court head and she done it again that
was so funny she goes the producers like
was what did you have a quartet like
yeah court at it was so funny and I'm
feeling - I'm really I might add Chet is
more like a style of a band than not
look at the number is the number no I
know but like culturally like you think
the core tenet is a couple people's true
but not to Cameron with her etiquette
like that's true and it's just funny
that it happened again
and I still am loving I love Cameron I
don't agree with her in this particular
initiative but I'm still feeling the
same way that I did and I do think she
things turn a little bit when they show
the preview for the next couple weeks
things are different
yeah so worth noting also let's talk
about LeAnn versus Carrie bring up what
- listen I don't know there was a caller
I was for - Carrie with the sea yeah
Carrie with a guy she can breathe again
I don't know I just call her Carrie
housewife Carrie
um she's thought that was an actual
housewife um her fight with LeAnn is so
incredibly stupid their relationship
makes absolutely no sense likely I was
gonna invite her to her wedding when a
they just met and B they don't even like
each other like the whole invitations
thing and when it comes to the wedding
and just like them comparing like LeAnn
is inviting everyone to her wedding so
that she's all upset when they don't
invite her to a girls night but like
first of all she's not friends with half
the girls are not even under terms and B
it's like you went you comparing the two
like I was gonna bet you to my wedding
tonight like it's just so weird cuz you
shouldn't be inviting these people to
your wedding
yeah or you shouldn't be inviting them
like add up giving them their
invitations beauties fat for like the
way that she's doing it also thirty
percent of the post postal mail oh my
god that is so funny also when [ __ ] what
was I gonna say
Frick don't go don't go hold on oh she
has a party in the morning where she
doesn't invite half of the women and
then those women who weren't invited get
others like and she's upset that she's
not invited when like you were the one
who didn't invite them first if they had
been invited to that couples shower they
would have 100% invited her to girls
night you mean Carrie was only one it
wasn't about that yeah yeah Carrie girls
night yeah and Carrie and Leon our
friends it's not like they're going on a
trip it's dinner like why everyone's to
be invited to everything
no but the reason why
houses of Dallas is right now at a
perfect formula is because there's not
one person where like where everyone the
viewers hate and we want them off the
show but there's this like deeply
entrenched they all get along at time
there's implacable arguments there's
multiple arguments but there's this like
deep-seated like we don't actually like
each other we're not each other's people
so there will always be fights and each
housewife who's fighting is always held
accountable at some point and the
problem with Lisa Vanderpump should be
that she was like people really didn't
like her like Erika Jayne like they just
aren't each other's people but the
arguments weren't balanced because Lisa
Vanderpump would never have to answer
for her sins and so now that she's off
the show and have you been seeing those
articles that Beverly Hills the season
that they're filming it now and there's
no footage everyone's getting along so
boring yeah but it's like probably
because Vanderpump is gone but
Vanderpump would have been fine on the
show like if she had showed up to the
reunion if she ever [ __ ] apologized
for anything that she did that's why I
think Brandi Glanville is like the
perfect sort of yep house eyes villain
because like she'll sir [ __ ] up but
she'll also own up to it apologize not
apologize keep things interesting as
opposed to Lisa who can do whatever she
wants and get away with it
totally everything comes back to the
sander prob also the midseason trailer
came out for the rest of the season
there was like a lot of talk about LeAnn
and carry their relationship gets much
much worse and she keep for furniture
eyes like that Mexican she says like a
few really like kind of racist things
here when she called the insurer a fat
cow mm-hmm so people are very upset and
we haven't seen it yet so obviously we
don't what the context is but like never
and you should never call someone like
it she go there like that little puny
Mexican like she just keeps saying
Mexican it's like who cares she's from
Mexico like it's there other things for
you call her mean like I just a weird to
keep referring to someone by their
nationality and like makes me you know
think but I'm also loving new Carey be
new too I think she's great and she
keeps like standing her ground it's like
she's not intimidated by anyone but she
also speaks in a manner that's like
she's very soft-spoken so you would
think oh my god she can't handle this
argument but then she handles herself
like a champ I almost I think she really
likes Brandis Stephanie and lets you add
Jandra and I think there's a real
friendship there when they were all
sitting having girls night like I think
they were really excited and I think
partly reason why she got so upset is
like you really did we're in the girls
right like I was having so much fun
these are the people that I just met but
I'm really like starting to create
friendships with that I just wants to
spend time with them but no now I'm
sitting here arguing with you and you
ruin my night yeah I agree
silly this
the mid-season trailer it looks really
good you should've seen it yet um and
that's all she wrote thank you guys so
much posting to this very special
episode of the morning toast feel free
to go back and listen to our wonderful
arrangement of Kanye West's new song
close serviced closed on Sunday his
album comes out tomorrow episodes not
sponsored but we just support people who
support us his album comes out tomorrow
it's called Jesus is king jesus is king
it's gonna be available everywhere I
presume it was supposed to come out a
couple weeks ago so it might come out
tomorrow but I actually really feel like
it it's coming out tomorrow yeah we love
you guys thank you so much for listening
to the morning Tosa millennial Morning
Show and we have a new episode of the
patreon up we sat down with Olivia and
Zach they just got back from their
honeymoon it was our first time seeing
them so we answered all of your
questions and our questions about their
trip on a podcast episode for the
patreon it was honestly like such a cute
episode they're so [ __ ] cute yeah
these are the million I know but if you
want to catch the cute bug listen to the
episode because also there's just like
some great traveling recommendations and
you get to hear all about how their trip
was and feel free to continue to listen
to the morning toast the millennium
morning show we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so feel free to subscribe to us
I mean YouTube leave this video thumbs
up comment we also available on as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
it's I Tunes Spotify to stitcher public
video I our radio cast box oh and like
feel free to like share our song with
Kanye like tweet out him like you should
listen to the morning toes yeah we love
you guys thank you so much have a
wonderful day
you